hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play pizza delivery
version 2.0 now this is supposedly a
much scarier version than the last one
because the last one frankly well was
kind of silly but anyway I've been told
that this is horrifyingly bad in every
way and so let's try it it's late you
have reached the Last House on the
delivery list deliver the pizza quickly
in return home warning this game is only
suitable for gamers of 15 years and
above please quit this game if you were
suffering from heart diseases you're
frightened or offended by darkness
disturbing graphics and loud sounds do
not play this game well okay
bring it on click to continue okay
ooh what's much more colorful than the
last time around it's actually really
nice there's my moped again where's my
big ol beat oh there it is ok so some
epi to place some a random pizza ha ha
very clever guy and what the hell is
that just a gout of water spouting out
of that weeping willow yeah that makes
sense but ok this is a very nice place
lots of cool ornaments but I'm not here
for any of that I'm here to get my wit
scared out of me ding dong hello anybody
home who is it pizza delivery
oh I'm upstairs please come on in
I'll be there in a minute squeak ok now
we're inside the house and wow that is a
weird picture ok someone's being eaten
by a giant that's cool and all better
place to pizza on the table yeah some of
the decor in this place is rather
disturbing man is that candle Jack Lou
okay I don't know what that is Cthulhu
er who knows okay put the pizza on the
table I'm guessing this table here OOP
some a random pizza place okay so now
I'm waiting for this lady for me
upstairs oh haha
now we'll go visit her I guess oh okay
all the lights turned off and now
there's only one candle ma'am can you
see up there
uh-huh I have my phone I could see from
its lie all righty
do you want me to come up and visit you
oh I can't even go up the stairs yet
damn it man those paintings are creepy
crap I should tell her that I'm a clue a
phobic I don't even know what that means
okay anyway oh I'm gonna run up oh oh
starting whatever the hell ma'am I need
to go oh wow she is taking a hell lot of
time Sokolow phobia just scared of the
dark
locked uh-oh that's not a good thing
get them see um I'll be back when the
power comes back I got to leave like now
but it's locked
how can I leave that seems to be okay
what the foop was that let's go upstairs
and check things ain't doing so good in
my department oh okay
how'd you feel a strange mother baby
don't do that to me don't do that to me
game I see the paintings on the wall and
now I grabbed a candle well the music is
definitely intensified a bit and let's
go upstairs ma'am ma'am okay I will
admit that this game got suddenly a lot
creepier they did definitely a good job
tiny Playhouse little tricycle ma'am you
okay ma'am ma'am where'd you go let me
just take the money just take the money
and get out of here man she's not here
got money for the pizza I can go home I
can go home
this pizza delivery is not that
important man just get out of the house
maybe she is downstairs gosh I hope not
cuz that would be weird
ma'am are you here here ma'am
hmm what is it oh it's her phone okay
it's like this is playing out a lot like
the first game what is so much better
they definitely did vast improvements on
how this goes the atmosphere is just
stellar now I love it
the sounds be all good and stuff okay
hello Oh God
what was that like a stretchy piece of
pizza what what what what the hell okay
all right we're nothing weird happening
here I didn't see like a spaghettified
Burt oh that oh thank you honey
no no you don't can't do what anymore I
love you that much
hello hello lady no thank you oh hey it
was like oh man hey uh that was kind of
funny because it looked like I don't
know have you ever guys heard of a
janilla the thing from team fortress no
okay nevermind then that's okay my heart
can't take this anymore but I can't get
out of this place probably one of you
guys have heard of vegetal a that was a
I don't never mind don't walk or you
will die okay
not walking not moving not moving
perfectly still
okay can I walk now I died
how long did I have to wait ah come on
no what bull honkey I died or I know I
died but it came over Oh
Hongki alright hang on I'm gonna walk
forward in time while I get back to
where I was so okay hello everybody I'm
back to where I was before in my heart
is not going to explode this time maybe
maybe it is maybe it won't I have no
idea my heart can't take this anymore
ah I need to stop moving my heart
nothing's real it's all my disease so
I'm not gonna move I am NOT gonna move
until something happens okay I better
watch the screen okay something at it
okay watch screen but there's something
buying you okay it's getting slowly
darker that's for sure why is that why
is that a thing and now it's pitch black
good great okay hello dot dot dot did I
fall asleep
is it over maybe not Oh was that all a
nightmare
no hello am I still in my house sleeping
in my bed no these are all questions
that could be answered if you opened
your friggin eyes nope you're still here
good job everybody you're a failure I
can't even move my mouse something's
gonna happen oh no now I can't okay can
I move without dying please pretty
pretty pretty please why is this
happening to me I don't know I don't
care but I'm assuming that I can move
now that death mechanic is really sucks
even though they told me I need to find
the key to the main door okay all righty
then what happened to my candle the
candle is out need the matchbox from
upstairs first okey-dokey
what's gonna happen while I'm trying to
get it hello hello hello hello okay got
it
light it nothing behind me they did IIIi
really have to say they did an amazing
improvement on this game hi hi there are
you real I know what you are looking for
don't let him enslave you the one who
listens for your steps the one who
enslaved my family okay I will set you
free follow me I don't think I want to
I don't want to follow you you're a
creepy little non-animated a tall girl
tiny itty-bitty tiny you're like way too
tiny to be real why were you looking at
Oh over here Oh got it find the keywords
go okay main door I don't care getting
out of a bag that's all right oh come on
uh-oh
Hongki okay guys I'm back for one last
time man that is annoying I have to go
through all of that over again now I
need to go get the match to light my
candle man game mechanics like that
should not be frustrating I mean it's
understandable that your players gonna
make a mistake but like to go through
all of the beginning dialogue over again
and repeat things just destroys the
atmosphere especially in a war game it's
just totally takes me out of being
afraid of anything and I'm just turned
into being frustrated so I'm gonna
follow this little girl and if I I know
the route that I need to run to run away
from the giant Satan looking Diablo
whatever and whatever let's just do this
let's do this I will statue free follow
me what that was that weird okay anyway
following love the animations you got
going on here they're just incredible
okay so now I need to run around this
pillar hell over here
so Satan looking thing big giant Diablo
which way you go which were you going
Nords where you go oh that way oh wow oh
not fair yeah you stay there you think
about what you've done
oh that closet in there I need to go
into that club so come this way a little
bit
come this way come this way are you
stuck you better be there's a closet in
here hide in the closet in the clock get
in in in in in pizza sweet it didn't see
me walk in here or anything
how did you be to get in here Oh what
that was there something to my right I
thought I saw something but I didn't see
it follow the pieces okay this is
somatically similar to the end of the
other one I was so close to the end and
frik a frak up Brickell a Kaluga when
I'm panicked I had no time to read that
I need to died the closet I think I did
read but even when I got to it I was
already running in the wrong direction
whatever I don't care let's just see
what the ending has for me and then I
will be done I'm gonna follow the pieces
literally jump one free piece to the
next not moving out of the path at all
this is a lot of pizza whose oh hi hi
Wow I couldn't move okay that was the
end okay good I was supposed to die
there what the hell
what oh hi Oh little girl I knew it I
knew it I knew it little girl I knew it
I know I knew that little girl yo he can
y'all play together ha ha I love that
little dance they're doing at the end
there okay oh hi little girl girl I hate
being frustrated in the organ that was a
terrible decision to make death work
like that girl
I'm not saying make death not a mechanic
but not make death completely exit out
of the game and you have to go through
all the dialogue again completely
destroying the atmosphere that you would
so well build up and that it was going
good for so long I might have actually
been scared at the ending if I hadn't
have gone through it twice so anyway
that's all I have to say about that so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
ah
Oh
I'm pretty good